[Music]  the last time I had sex was like a few  months ago in London with a stranger  type personally different strangers yeah  I'm at which is good run where'd you  meet a guy in London one was at a party  one was on that dating site ryuk on the  app you see their picture right it's a  little gay no because they put like a  montage so they have to put like seven  pictures of doing different things and  they put it to a song oh great man who  does that is already like already not  attracted to him I did have sex with a  celebrity like a year or two ago that  you'd be interested in but I can't talk  about him because I was a movie actor or  comedian both he's media and a movie  actor yeah what happened what went wrong  without nothing we just had sex like a 5  or 6 times and it was really funny and  then did you find yourself falling in  love with him no I mean we were it was  pretty like kind of drunken escapades  Wow  well good for you thank you it's great  sex really fun